[Musique]
parce que je suis hypersensible à
l'hypnose il ya des gens qui sont pas
réceptifs du tout donc ça marche pas et
moi je suis très réceptifs sans doute
parce que très sensible donc j'accepte
de me laisser aller
donc c'est souvent moi mais vous allez
voir il va croire qu'il est attaqué par
des mousses s'il n'était pas dans la
jungle au nom tu as la peau sucré
ah oui très sucrée mais fermé à non
alors franchement moi l'hypnose
alors d'abord j'adore pas ça parce que
pendant trois jours après j'ai des
nausées
je suis hyper sensible et si j'étais
acteur ça se saurait donc je suis
vraiment hypnotisé je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe j'ai l'impression qu'une
enveloppe charnelle à loin de moi a fait
quelque chose mais j'ai pas l'impression
que c'est moi
donc si la question c'est est-ce que
j'ai truqués ou pas ce n'est pas bien
mais j'ai un coût de 2 contre jean
michel maire
hier j'ai regardé l'émission j'ai bondi
parce que même avec qui fait l'écho
dimanche
c'est faux dit n'importe quoi on peut
regarder si vous voulez ces bambins
merci le régime mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison ça l'est parce que c'est lui
qui a laissé mer mer etc rihanna je suis
pas adepte de la magie noire mais j'y
crois il ya des gens qui ont des
pouvoirs sur les autres et mieux vaut
s'en prémunir
hélas je crois qu'elle elle n'est pas
sensible à l'hypnose aller trop sous
contrôle mais je vais essayer d'y un
joueur si ça marche alors maxime gainey
comme ça peut-être qu'il arrêterait dire
des conneries mais il est même pas sûr
non j'étais est pas maxime des lilas
personne maxime daigneault le
chroniqueur maxime déni à chaque fois il
est à côté il ya à contre-pied il est
quasiment n'importe quoi donc mon boulot
est hostile et la différence d'âge c'est
quand même de le redresser et de fer
qu'il arrête de dire des conneries ça
sera mieux pour tout le monde et pour
lui et pour moi c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
sortez-vous non non non maintenant j'ai
essayé une fois enfin j'ai parlé avec
des médecins des clauses médical ils
m'ont dit que j'étais trop réceptif à
l'hypnose a trop peur d'être au réceptif
à l'hypnose pour le sexe des rives où on
ferait jamais parce qu'on sait pas dans
quel état sont vous mettrez au québec ça
vous donne envie de bouger
la danse est folle comment l'aider
comment le coma comment le désactiver
pour le dessin
[Musique]